journalism is under attack like never
before
telling their story how would you
describe this outbreak something like an
apocalypse you're going to be really
tired you're going to be really scared
it's too dangerous you know anyone who
says they're not scared is like anything
can happen
I sometimes wonder how have we managed
to get out of this
genuinely believe in what we do it's
clearly Mark's press to show the truth
all right this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover an injustice
this is the result of ethnic cleansing I
don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that I'm Alex
Crawford I'm Stuart Ramsey and this is
hot spots
[Music]
coming up on hot spots they don't know
that there's a world outside they don't
know that there's possibilities my teams
in Guatemala were the climate crisis is
costing lives I actually found it very
shocking to look at that small child and
and see how God he was
and we're the first journalists to enter
the town ransacked by Islamic extremists
in Mozambique that was probably the most
harrowing part of the trip it was very
eerie
we knew that there were communities that
were struggling to eat there's poverty
there's hunger and malnutrition so the
two and a half year old will suffer as a
direct result of having a system they
have to make this terrible Choice one of
the volcanoes here in Guatemala is going
a bit mad today going from farming to
volcanoes is a whole different ball game
right next to the volcano steam spewing
out I'm pretty terrified actually I have
one big volcano
well Central Americans have been heading
towards the United States border for
decades trying to get into the country
but in recent years and under recent
American administrations of Migrant
crisis has become hugely politicized
the migrants themselves have been
characterized as rapists and criminals
just trying to get into the United
States to cause trouble
however there's been indicators to all
of us for a long time that that probably
isn't as simple as that and it's perhaps
just not even the case and that made us
think we have to perhaps go back to the
root causes of part of these migrant
Caravans
I have been covering the migrant crisis
in Central America for well since I've
started working with him then he was
working on the migrant crisis long
before then but at that time we were in
Mexico and near the border with in
Tijuana near the border with the us and
we we documented the movement of Migrant
Caravans we'll just say we're going to
try to jump the fence into the United
States
it was clear that many of these people
were escaping terrible violence at home
gang violence police corruption
government corruption and in many cases
where economic migrants a significant
number were also people who were
literally forced out of their homes not
by anyone but by one thing and that was
climate change and so in a way they were
a new form of Migrant they were actually
climate migrants Guatemala is one of the
countries where this has become a real
problem
so when we started looking into
Guatemala the first thing that struck us
were the Hurricanes that had happened in
2020 but then the more we started to
research the topic and talk to people
and experts in country the more we
started to realize that actually the
Hurricanes were sort of a freak weather
event that was part of a much much
bigger problem and the problem was
mainly drought
sometimes it's meant to be raining in
its baking hot sometimes it's meant to
be baking hot and it's raining and then
you have a huge number of hurricanes
that have hit the region with a greater
frequency than anyone has ever seen
before
we knew before we set off for Guatemala
that there were communities small
communities who lived in quite remote
mountainous areas that were struggling
to eat it was as simple as that we knew
that the country has got one of the
highest rates of child malnutrition in
the world that was becoming worse and
worse because of climate change
is the town that's at the center of
massive irrigation and Market farming
etc for Guatemala it's surrounded by
very high hills and that's where the
poorer members of society do their
farming
so it was myself and Stuart and Dan all
working together as a team we've done a
lot of stories together in Central
America it's very familiar territory for
our team we've got a lot of equipment
with us so that's because we're having
to carry
all sorts of protective equipment and on
top of that we carry an awful lots of
milk for
the children in these Villages that
we're about to visit where they're all
suffering from malnutrition
there's a Stewart's cowboy boots a lot
laughs
today we're going up into the poor
really poor regions the mountain area
and we're seeing farmers who really
struggle to live apparently a lot of the
men are no longer there because they've
had to leave to find work elsewhere
and there's a lot of malnutrition
we would be doing a lot of driving on
this trip and you know Not only would we
be doing a lot of driving but we would
need really good 4x4 Vehicles because
we'd be driving a lot in quite
challenging conditions
and at certain times you actually have
to just walk up you walk between the
villages there are no roads linking to
various houses it's just Pathways and
that is where the people who really do
suffer the most are to be found
well they have pretty meager crop yields
here as a rule even in the best of times
but now a combination of no rain
intense Heat
and a hurricane means that 100 of the
local crop has been destroyed
it's all gone
Eduardo is extremely desperate he's one
of the few Farmers that's tried to stay
just effectively the head of the Farmers
Union in the area but I mean there isn't
really any Farmers Union that's him
[Music]
it's become so unpredictable
that they can't it's difficult to plan
it's difficult to have any expectation
and then of course you respond to is
there any point in planting
we knew that in a lot of these Villages
and communities there were actually a
lot of women and children and not many
men because all the men had left so we
wanted to speak to these women and part
of us being able to do that is an
amazing woman named Sophia
Sophia is basically the founder of
Antigua al-rescato they were set up
initially because of the volcanic
eruptions that took place in Antigua and
then once the threat of that particular
volcano had passed they started to look
into the need within their own country a
bit more and malnutrition and child
hunger became something that Sophia
identified early on this is the area in
which most of the crops do not grow all
year round there's poverty there's
hunger and malnutrition
she is an absolute Lifeline for the
women of these communities and it takes
a long time for her to get to know them
she said that when she first arrived
they didn't like any Outsiders being
there they don't know that there's a
world outside
they don't know that there's different
kinds of living they they don't know
that there's possibilities
[Music]
the first home that Sophia took us to in
in this community she had explained that
there was a woman she was heavily
pregnant the last time Sophia had seen
her she was eight months pregnant she
lives in this little house they lost all
the corn yeah and now they live all
together all the women that have been
left behind in abandoned they live in
the same house
while some of the women take care of the
kids some can go out and work a little
get some food they're just creating this
small community of women who are
supporting each other and this is just
really like an act of survival yes it's
an after survival yeah
it's a very
complicated
[Music]
so climbed over a fence and you know
walked through crops and I say crops but
they were dead crops walked through them
and walk this little Trail to her home
and we walked in and she was saying
hello hello and we couldn't hear
anything it was Pitch Black
we realized actually there was somebody
there and it was this lady who just had
her baby a few hours before
[Music]
the mum was more than happy to see a
Sophia and a more than happy to for her
to take her take the baby away and to
check her and to weigh her and see that
she was okay
but this was a classic case of the lady
already had another child that will have
to be fed they live with about 20 Q
worth of corn that's about three and a
half dollars worth of corn per week for
a family of six and you need to add the
fact that if she has a daughter that's
two and a half years old and when
there's no food she breastfeeds the two
and a half year old
so right now this two and a half year
old girl will
they she will not have mom's milk so
basically we're expecting her to go down
in weight so the two and a half year old
will suffer as a direct result of having
a Sister yes and it's not just an
emotional thing about their bond being
broken it's about her not getting breast
milk for Mom they have to make this
terrible choice and it's happening
everywhere
newborn babies seem
vulnerable when you first see them it
does it doesn't matter whether you see
them in a fancy Hospital in the first
world country or in the conditions where
we met this baby but you can't help but
have a little bit hope maybe that things
will be different for this this child I
just thought here's a a small Life Born
Into essentially a climate emergency and
this little girl and little ones like
her are actually what it's all about
it's what our climate fight now is about
it
[Music]
the next family we met in the community
was Isabel Perez and her children it
wasn't very easy to get to them
they live very high up on one of the
mountains and tops and we had to park
near the bottom and do a little bit of a
track up to see her
it was the middle of the day and it was
pitch dark inside and lying on the bed
fast asleep with two little boys he's
two and a half he had just been in a
Recovery Center because he's too little
and too light for his age
and
he's two months old wow I just couldn't
get over how small they were and then
looked closer at the two-month-old baby
who only weighed five and a half pounds
he was just a little bit bigger than the
newborn that we just met and he was two
months old
[Music]
I actually found it very shocking to
look at that small child and and see how
gaunt he was and I think for me it
brought home the story it was the
picture of the story
um it was that direct connection that we
were looking for
he was taken to a recovery center but
because here they don't wear diapers
and the recovery center they put him a
diapers so he got a horrible diaper rash
right
last week that we came I gave him this
100 pint that I'm always carrying around
so it's like almost gone yeah it's worth
the treat oh yeah and even that sort of
a simple rash like that could actually
prove very very dangerous indeed right
yes
because they're so weak
I think without Sophia and her
leadership with her NGO
significant proportion of the children
being born in that environment now would
die
the weather systems have now become so
unreliable there is no way they can
plan to say we'll get through this year
we'll be all right next what they're
probably saying is we'll we'll get
through this year will we get through
the next and will we get through the one
after that
is the tummy definitely extended because
of that
well the thing is
malnutrition and parasites that's the
combination and that's why people see
their chubby faces and people believe oh
they're fat because they're facing
chubby but they're just retaining water
yeah
so he's got a belly but there's nothing
in it
yeah filming with the community and you
know Dan had the Drone up and we're
getting some sweeping shots of the
valleys and that kind of thing and
various social media started peaking on
this on the story of the volcanoes in
Antigua Guatemala
so it's just quite active really yes yes
you can see which one is it it's the
same way from 2018 yes he's an angry one
yeah
he's a feisty Dominique was having to
speak to London and just say listen just
keep an eye on this so um I'm calling to
let you know that one of the volcanoes
here in Guatemala is going a bit mad
today
because you know going from one story
like that which is one's about farming
two volcanoes is a whole different
ballgame and that was so you know to
sort of plan and work out how do you go
you know how do you cover a volcanic
eruption safely it's it's something one
that you do actually have to think about
but we might find ourselves um starting
here doing one story and ending this
trip on an entirely different story the
conclusion we we came to was that we had
enough
um on the story we were doing to
actually go to Antigua Guatemala and
find out what was happening with the
volcanoes
in 2018 one of the volcanoes Volcan de
Fuego which is the volcano fire erupted
and spewed billions of tons of rock and
Ash and you know the lava flowed about
eight kilometers down into communities
around and it was a it was a completely
tragic event
it completely engulfed the communities
that live on the Basin around the
volcano
there was a lot of anxiety that what
what happened in 2018 would happen again
and that there could be a big eruption
we're going to meet some of the people
who live around the volcano and see if
they're going to prepare to leave or not
because definitely the activity is worse
than it's been for a long while things
volcanoes they go bad they go very bad
very quickly I think so
if
is uh there's only so many precautions
you can take sort of not going I suppose
but uh we're going to look
it was making a lot of rumbles it was
making all the indicators of of a big
explosion that had happened actually
only a few years before and killed huge
numbers of people in the in that
vicinity and we were quite surprised so
many of these communities are still
there and still populated
what is this communities and there's
lots of them around here or actually on
the volcano are in incredibly vulnerable
to the lava it's flowed through here
before and obviously from the gases that
can come off a major explosion over a
hundred and eighty thousand people live
in these communities on the volcano and
the real crucial point on which is the
point that they made to us is yes they
know it's dangerous they're used to
making noises that that that's part of
life
and you wouldn't think of leaving
and perhaps this is the key
they can't afford to leave
it was particularly difficult filming
volcanoes because it seemed like they
were intentionally hiding from us it's
fair to say it was driving Dan
absolutely crazy to the point that we
gave up on Fuego after trying forever we
could hear it but we couldn't see it and
we were right underneath it but it was
just covered in its own Ash and and
smoke but also just in very very low
cloud
so we decided that what we'd do is to
climb up the other volcano that was also
erupting and that's pakaya
we had to get permission from police and
park authorities but we did it by just
driving up and chatting
um
I've said we can we can go up and
they're going to take us up and they say
we'll see it and so we began everyone
piling into four-wheel drives to begin
this drive further and further up the
side of the volcano which I was getting
more and more scared because on a number
of occasions one we've got a volcano
erupting two we don't know if it's going
to get worse three we're driving up the
side of the mountain in this tiny Road
it's pretty rock and roll
it's been about
four there's a precipitic drop on the
right hand side going down thousands of
feet
just simply couldn't get any further up
sort of just felt slightly better being
on foot as well rather than being in the
car
I don't know why but it just felt like
that
the higher up we were getting the more
antsy Stewart was getting now I know
Stewart's afraid of heights and you know
we were quite High
that's it
is it explaining
no right next to the volcano you can
hear it
Steam and spewing out I'm pretty
terrified actually I just have one big
volcano sure
I was really scared it was rumbling and
you know sometimes a camera can can't
quite get across the what it feels like
when you're quite near to something
I'm concerned
and I can see steam coming out of all
sorts of holes
when Stewart is quiet it means Stewart
is nervous and there was a lot of quiet
Heights and loud noises
I'm really high up
and there's really loud noises because
of the volcano but then I got to a point
Stu was like right we're getting off
this this mountain now and so we did
Dan was unhappy because because sun was
in the wrong place
the white cloud with a bright light
behind a black object in the middle of
the day at noon I mean come on
what you couldn't actually film The
Volcano pretty much snow
we'll come back tonight don't worry by
the end of the day usually around five
or six the the clouds actually drop and
the volcano exposes itself
we sat in a field
that we were given special permission to
be in by the owner which had a very good
what he said as a good shot of the lava
flow
extremely dark
and we're in a cloud and there's
apparently a huge volcano just there we
just can't see
I think we got there at about
four in the afternoon and I think we
left at about three in the morning and I
was absolutely Frozen
finally finally with about I think I've
fallen asleep in the car and then I
trudged over and Dan was packing up his
kit and I said what else what are you
doing he said I got it it was one hell
of a fireworks show at the end
good
special
and he had like four a few minutes it
opened up and he could see the mountain
and he got the shots that he wanted
when the volcano was erupting you could
feel that under your feet and that makes
you feel really really small as a human
being but I would say today probably
this erupting volcano was one of the
most impressive natural spectacles I've
ever seen awesome I think would be the
word that you would describe or some
power and energy at the same time
the next day we woke up and it was the
most clear day the Sun was shining and
you could see Fuego in all its Glory
from our hotel kilometers away how is it
possible that on the day we're leaving
this is the day where you have the
clearest view of the volcano and Dan was
so frustrated
the volcano that decided to hide itself
from us when we were on it is now fully
available for everyone to see and
Incredibly watching from the year
a bit like judging hurricanes you can't
plan those you can't plan eruptions or
earthquakes it's just you've got to sort
of go with no hint of irony you've got
to go with the flow
when we go and and do these stories and
tell people's stories in this case the
climate change and the dry Corridor and
child malnutrition and then you know the
volcanoes and their impact on the
communities around them we we come and
we go you leave there and people leave
Impressions on you and Sophia was
someone who left a she left a real
impression on me and you know her and
her NGO are kind of self-appointed
Guardians they're sort of self-pointed
angels they've traveled all the way
she is a remarkable woman and she is
away a link interestingly between the
uncertainty of volcanic eruptions and
the uncertainty of the weather
conditions and the effect it's had on
people
some of it
can actually be attributed to man-made
problems and perhaps you can't stop
volcanic eruptions but you probably can
stop climate change
up next
area Governor starts striding off down
that high speed with suddenly thinking
oh wow well actually we're going into
the heart of where we want to go
thank you
there were many displaced people who'd
fled the fighting they're all
wrong you could feel the exasperation
all sort of boiled up and this is now a
militarized area it was very eerie they
were tied with their hands behind their
back and their heads were cut off come
on
I think Mozambique is the Islamic State
Insurgency that most of the world just
hadn't heard about
Mozambique is a country which most
people probably only associate with
sun-drenched beaches and yet in the
underbelly there's this
growing Insurgency
the Insurgency started officially in
2017. it's branded itself with the flag
of Isis there's estimations that you
know close to 700 000 people have been
displaced up to you know 3 000 people
have died the truth is nobody knows
what's interesting is that at roughly
the same time that they discovered this
giant oil gas field you suddenly had the
makings of this Insurgency it was very
violent horrific attacks but they were
very much on a small scale and then four
years later just as the oil and gas
exploration was really taking off there
was the most audacious extremist attack
which sent
tens of thousands of people fleeing in
Terror we're just getting some breaking
news out of maputo the capital of
Mozambique and that is dozens of people
were killed in an attack in the northern
town of Palmer there was a real shortage
of pictures so it was hard to know
exactly what was going on but what was
clear was that there was a terrorist
incident occurring
I've worked in Africa for a long time so
I developed some very strong contacts
within the Mozambique government so we
had been given this extremely rare
access and invitation to come and see
what was going on
so we're waiting to be taken up north
and
Alex has communicated with the president
I'm desperately trying to persuade them
to give us an interview instead sending
those topics that we might want to cover
which is how they can how they can
convince people that it's secure and
we're going to find out ourselves
probably in the next hour or so just how
secure it is and it's vitally important
for Mozambique the whole region the
whole of Africa that they get this
Terror threat under control because it's
spreading
there was a hell of a lot of unknown
about the trip we didn't know entirely
what we were going to be shown so it was
just to get there and establish some
facts and see for ourselves what had
occurred
thank you as soon as we land in a fungi
we walk into the little Airport
and there's a whole load of people
immediately we assumed that they must be
some of the people who'd fled and we
just started talking to them straight
away what were they doing they're
killing people how
they shoot people even they're following
are shooting words
then we run over they were describing
really chilling graphic violent scenes
well we jumped One River we found the
people through the gun they were
shooting one and one Pips another and
there's another people also just
chopping at the people so we tried to
run away I can't imagine how terrifying
that must have been I'm thinking maybe
this is all the fleeing civilians that
we're going to see so we talk to as many
as we possibly can try and get as many
sort of first-hand eyewitness accounts
from them how have you managed to eat
and drink have you managed to survive
it's not easy
it's not easy okay
the only way you're going to get into
Palma was with the military
outside Palmer
and from where they've tried to beat
back the the militants
whatever
moral
company
we met up with the governor he
introduced himself and said I'm going to
take you to a whole new housing area
we've been told that there were many
displaced people who'd fled the fighting
in Palmer but no one had very accurate
ideas of exactly how many people there
were there
and as we got closer and closer the
crowd got bigger and bigger and bigger
awful lot of people here and there a lot
of them just seem to be living rough
difficult to tell numbers straight away
but thousands I'd say
definitely thousands
the aid agencies estimated over 20 000
people
I think like us the governor was
absolutely gobsmacked by how many people
there were
yeah
my name is
[Applause]
for me that was probably the most
towering part of the trip they're all
[Music]
and it all sort of boiled up we need
food we need food we need food thank you
not good they've been there for two
weeks and nothing had been done for them
[Applause]
I think the Mozambique government they
appeared to not realize how strong the
feeling of discontent was in that area
I like oh it's a bit bumpy but wow I
wasn't I wasn't expecting to see so many
people there's a lot of people there
the obvious aim of it all and the reason
why we were there was to get into Palmer
to to be able to see where the attack
happened if there's any chance we can
land just
what the terrorist s done the vandalism
and the
reason what it was planned to be done
um but the security they are not
yet because they are still working there
finally got into the helicopter and
we've been told that this was just going
to be a flyover so we probably weren't
going to land
and suddenly the helicopter starts
getting closer and closer to the ground
we landed in a middle of a football
field we got out we didn't know what to
expect
okay we're in Palmer and this is now a
militarized area lots of soldiers
they're very much positive
we have a quick chat with the soldiers
there
without our minder and our chaperone how
far the terrorists from here
are they still in the town yes yes
they're still in the town how many
um
well I'm thinking
pretty sure this isn't the message the
government is trying to put out
I don't think it was very long after we
got dropped into the perimeter of Palmer
that these people started coming out of
the bush
families holding children and babies
and talking about hiding out there for
nearly two weeks
and they were hungry so they were
immediately given
food and something to drink
the governor starts striding off down
that High Street we suddenly thinking oh
wow well actually we're going into the
heart of where we want to go
foreign
[Music]
it was very eerie
[Music]
this was obviously so recent
there are signs of Destruction
everywhere dead animals we've seen dead
bodies in hallways almost every one of
these buildings has been trashed and
this one appears to have been set on
fire
this was nearly two weeks after the
attack
no one had felt secure enough to go in
and do any of the clearing up at this
stage
the damage and destruction is extensive
come along in here roof down building
satellite these are administrative
offices and every
house that you can see through there has
been set alight
well this is classic Islamic extremist
tactics favored by ISIS burn key
infrastructure like hospitals schools
Banks post office homes just to
terrorize the people make them leave
this governor was just striding ahead
setting the pace
they didn't want to really just stop for
any length of time in any one place so
there was a feeling that they weren't
100 sure that the place was safe
I mean he was a former Tennis champion
apparently and extremely likable
character a very charismatic character
but there was no waiting around for
anybody
this guy was literally just running
running hey look over there hey hey are
you doing come look have a look he just
didn't stop you had answers back clothes
exhausted you're there filming
everything that moves just trying to
gather everything because you just don't
know what you're going to get next we
had no idea how long we were going to be
there for you're burning nervous energy
as well I thought he was quite Frank for
a politician how can you guarantee it
won't happen again at this I can't say
this I can't say I would put money on
most politicians around the world saying
well yeah we're going to do our best and
he just said straight away well no I
can't I can't guarantee that
there was a great deal of suspicion at
that time
on the way out they've arrested three
young men
the soldiers were clearly a bit edgy
about why these three young men of
fighting age were just knocking around
the area there was a lot of concern that
because they've been caught so off guard
the first time that it could happen
again
foreign
I wasn't immediately aware of how
important that was or you know
the exclusivity of it at the time
certainly when we got the pictures back
you realize actually yeah we are the
first International observers there on
the ground Alex joins me now live from
the town of Pember in Mozambique and
Alex you've been in Palmer do we know
where those jihadists are who attacked
Palmer on March 24th I mean that is a
fantastically difficult question and one
that the Mozambique military desperately
wants to have answered you realize then
that actually that was very difficult
and exclusive opportunity to get on the
ground and get pictures and for the
world to see what's happened in the
aftermath what the Mozambique
authorities want to find out what the
Mozambique military wants to hammer down
is how did they manage to do this and
where have they gone
we wanted to go and see the Amarula
Lodge which a lot of people had taken
refuge in including a lot of expats
so a few days later we got again another
early call we're going to go back
we're at a fungi airport
this area appears to be very secure
they've given us armed guards opening up
the roads which they say are now secure
and they want to take us to the Amarillo
Lodge where so many people were held
under siege by the militants
the military were taking a small group
of selected journalists
a lot more soldiers in Palma an awful
lot more people as they're trying to
encourage them to come back and try to
reassure them that they are safe again
and then we turn up at the Amarillo
Lodge
sorry can I just give you that no no
thank you
there'd be nearly 200 people trapped
there amongst them some of the expat
workers and the foreign workers and
they've been under siege at this Lodge
signs of Destruction all around
runes have been ransacked office
equipment has been thrown everywhere
the soldiers are now set up camp in the
middle of the town and outside here at
the Amarula Lodge when we got into the
lodge obviously it was empty there was a
terrible terrible smell light bodies but
it wasn't it was rotting meat so all the
food stores full of fish full of meat
were rotting away in the blazing sun
and then just walking around all these
individual lodges individual rooms with
stuff scattered on the floor the
mattress is gone they've been taken away
broken glass people's clothes still all
over the place
you just try and picture what it was
like for the people who were holed up in
there for days on end with you know
enemies at the gate if you want one of
our guys gotten a phone call from
somebody that said that they were
attacking Palmer we got access to some
of the survivors who'd not only managed
to survive the attack but it also filmed
quite a lot of it on their mobile phones
foreign
there was this South African family
two brothers and a father
all three of them had got caught up in
this Siege at the Amarula Lodge
what happened inside that Lodge was
quite extraordinary
the gunfire just didn't stop the mortars
I mean you're talking about hundreds of
mortars it was an incredible tale of
fortitude with quite tragic consequences
love you bro
man
all right they honestly believed they
were going to be saved and you see their
Despair and their frustration growing
through these mobile phone Clips over
the number of days
[Music]
when they realize that no one's coming
back to save them they come up with this
desperate plan to mount their own Convoy
it's gonna be the driver of your life
right to bust out of it themselves
almost as soon as they break out they're
ambushed with shooting from the
extremists who lined up on the side of
the road where they knew the drivers
would be Adrian gets shot twice
I was holding her shoulder over the
bullet
trying to stop the blood and I was just
pumping out west gives this
heartbreaking description which is
obviously very very Vivid in his mind
and I was just shouting
that I love the man that I look after
his family
and that I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry that this has happened to
him
it was very very sad very sad
and I thought he did an incredible job
bringing home to everybody just how
terrifying that must have been
I guess it's human nature not to just
accept potential death
they just felt they had to do something
and you can't blame them really
found to take measures into their own
hands because nobody was coming to save
them decisions could have been taken
somewhere
to help them to save them and it didn't
happen
we were filming in the hotel grounds but
then just outside we were told by a
local chap that yeah he had helped bury
multiple bodies here what happened to
you knew that they were all beheaded it
was a horrific scene apparently buried
they were rotting corpses so they dug a
large hole and buried the bodies in
there have they taken them out yet no
they healed
we just wanted to film something it's a
huge part of the story we needed to
document that but as soon as we turned
out the military were straight away
whisking us away okay apparently these
these black dark parts of blood
we're going no no we need to know what's
going on no no they're not moving right
come on
time is over let's go we managed to get
a few words with him as we were walking
back away
and it was just really chaotic
living in Amarula with one Spirit how
many were there
around 12. you know this is a massive
element of the story and the military
were just trying to drag us out there as
quickly as they could
say all of them
sorry say again Tommy all the bodies
they Define there was tight they were
tied with their hands behind their back
and their heads were cut off yes
thank you
we tried very hard to stand up
the reports of beheadings at the Amarula
but we weren't able to confirm the
details
the truth is nobody knows how many
people were killed in the Palmer attack
and that's why you know just being able
to go there even for a short time to be
able to film even if it is just a
glimpse is so important because there is
not and they probably will not be
a thorough accounting
I don't think anyone came out of this
very well the Mozambique politicians
clearly didn't do enough to prevent this
happening
there was a lack of intelligence on the
ground in the build up to this then when
it did break out there wasn't a good
robust coordinated response to it and
then they didn't do enough to rescue or
help people so you can't actually kill
an idea and Isis
is using Africa to build its next base
and I think the International Community
is going to be caught short again just
like they were in Iraq and Syria if they
don't step up and start recognizing that
the spread of extremism in Africa is
very definitely not going away
[Music]
next time on hotspots my team and I are
in India as the country nears collapse
under the weight of the covet crisis
they were screaming out for oxygen the
definition of a hospital struggling to
cope people started to die in front of
us
and we're back in Brazil where the
pandemic is claiming a new type of thing
pregnant women were dying than anywhere
else on the planet I was not prepared
for that if you've got 500 000 plus dead
these figures are absolutely horrendous
until then you can find us on Twitter at
Alex Crawford sky and at Ramsay sky
see you next time
[Music]
gonna be the one that saves me
[Music]
and after all
you're my one
[Music]